i had a i had a guy actually follow me
into uh
uh the bathroom this is a true story uh
i'm in a stall you know i gotta go and
you know yeah while i'm in the bathrooms
like kevin can i get a picture and i'm
like you know because i'm obviously a
very big guy i i stand up for myself
immediately i say hey not in here you
wait until i'm done okay you go outside
i take it with you when i get outside
um and i go on the stall you close the
door and
you know you would expect whoever that
was to have left they're gone and i you
know i do what i got to do and it was a
it was one of those situations where i
had to be in there for a while
you know i'm in there
and you know
literally you know when you when you get
comfortable you start to take your time
and i'm on my phone i'm scrolling i'm
you know it's just it's a it's a it's a
comfortable and that's what you do with
the ball that's it
i get done and i like
get out the stall and close the door
he's right there he's like
man you're in there for a while
he's like can we get the picture i was
like i meant outside the bathroom man
off the bathroom i'm not taking a
picture with you in the bathroom but the
fact that he stood there like very
nicely the whole time
it made me feel obligated and i was like
hey just just come on selfie real quick
don't tell nobody you saw me in here
friends with jason statham every day
killing l.a and i get to my mike tyson
joke and that's where i usually get a
standing ovation and when i get to the
joke
nobody laughs because mike tyson is in
the building and i get to that joke and
somebody here mike is in here
and then it was a black girl and you
know there's a black girl egging on she
was sitting in the front what you gonna
do jamie you're gonna tell your little
joke
well congratulations on your 100th
birthday
now
i understand you went to universal
studios yesterday yes i did and you know
the wind was terrible oh okay i had a
skirt on and the wind is just blowing
like that and i was hanging on to my hat
and the kid came up and he says lady he
said you better stop hanging on your hat
and put your dress down you're showing
everything you got
and i said
i don't care what they see down there is
100 years old this is a brand new hat
we were like on a beach and then they
threw us a football and they're like
play football and all the other models
were like playing football like in a
pretty way you know like not me
i was all of the photos i've got a red
face covered in sweat my nostrils are
flared
and like at one point a girl yelled just
get her away from me
first time i met rodney dangerfield that
was uh
in florida to come it was the first
comedian that i met that was famous and
i was about 17 he came and he bumped me
at this club i was getting ready to go
and so dangerfield's here
and i was like oh no so you went up yeah
i got no respect killed it blew the
whole place out
then i had to go up after him and i did
my show i had a good set and i went up
after i said so it's a danger feeling i
was just thinking we're gonna go cause
back to mac was real dirt dirtier than
it was five years when i was 17. whoo
forget about it your act was dirtier
when you were 17. oh much dirtier much
dirty like the audience would sit there
looking
and afterwards i went up to dangerfield
saying so what'd you think and he said
we're gonna go with all of that and then
i saw him again maybe like
seven years later like after saturday
night live and after the movies no he
might not even remember this in a in a
bathroom in caesar's palace well and i'm
at the urinal and dangerfield walks up
and he looks over at me and he just goes
who knew
seven years later
hollywood knew that i was wanting to get
out of just doing action movies and do
comedies that's what i did then twins in
kindergarten cup and right like that
thank you
but so they came to me with this other
movie and uh i forgot what it was called
uh stopper my mother was my mama shoot
exactly that's right and so i read the
script and it was a business
and so i said to myself i'm not gonna do
this movie so then they went to sly
and then sly called me and he says hey
have they ever talked to him at you
about this movie and i said yes i was
thinking about doing it
this is a really brilliant idea
and so when he heard that because he was
in competition he immediately called him
and says look whatever it takes i do the
movie
so he did the movie wow because the
movie went major into the toilet
you are a diabolical man have you ever
seen a ghost
yeah no really no i've seen one and i've
felt them you know i mean you get vibes
from places you know i mean well let me
tell you about yeah i remember being a
kid in uh where was it new jersey my
sister was in that bed i was in this but
i was probably about nine we had a nanny
over there and i remember just sitting
there and i was looking up and towards
the doorway and then all of a sudden
this kind of suit
with no body no legs nobody in it kind
of came in and went like this and then
disappeared
it was double breasted it was white
we had invited to read the grinch how
the grinch stole christmas that's is
that a tradition they read that every
year for the kids there i don't know
i don't know
but they asked me
in this one year uh this last year and
uh and we asked if we could obviously
bring of course the boys and uh and we
got there
and they said here's the map room here's
where your boys can hang out go where
are the other kids they're like there
aren't any kids
uh i said okay but i'm reading the
grinch there that's right you're just
reading it to 200 adults
so
that doesn't seem right it didn't seem
yeah so i had to read the grinch to
the white the basically the cabinet and
the executive staff
[Laughter]
and
so i i i
and it was a surprise yeah
absolutely you thought it was going to
go a whole different way i thought it
was going to go a whole different way i
thought it was going to at least there'd
be children at my feet
and i'm just looking out at secretary of
defense robert gates
and and so i i assumed i thought well i
got to change gears here they're
probably going to want me to make it
funny i would think
you know i walk up there and i'm reading
the grinch so the only thing i could
think of was to read it
as as former president bush um
well that's
[Music]
so i
started by saying uh uh this is uh
i'm about to read the grinch who stole
christmas it's uh
dr seuss is one of my favorite books
even though he can and he is known as
getting tongue twistery at times
[Applause]
but it's a good piece of literature you
know
and uh
[Applause]
keep in mind grinch is a fictional
character
we've researched this the grinch is not
for real
but the whos the whos they they do live
in a small village in macedonia
uh
they're good people
cindy lou who and uh
space and time
it can't divide
unfortunately
[Music]
i did an impersonation of dave chappelle
in front of dave chappelle at eddie's
house i remember that night because
eddie was talking about going out and
doing stand-up mm-hmm and i was looking
at his house like you can't do stand-up
with
with the way this house is
because the house was so perfect
you know it's like you can't have a
perfect house like my house my house
stays sort of messed up because i want
to stay funny like you know i never i
never finished decorating all the way
there's a faucet in this one bathroom
that sprays out
and when i stan i stand in the hallway
to see people come out because you just
and people come out
[Applause]
but at the end of the night everybody
was trying to win funnier funniest of
the night you started circling around 2
30 whatever i didn't even try i was just
standing in the corner
but at one point
was standing rock eddie everybody and
dave says
look at jamie's shoes i said what about
my shoes
he said what i said what
and i was like man it's crazy look at
jamie's shooting i started saying yes
james my shoes dave it's crazy and then
he goes man this is wild man jamie is
doing impersonation to me this is wow
and then eddie is sitting there going
like
i'm gonna tell you one of the worst
things that happened to me okay uh i'm
having like a phenomenal shoe for those
people that play blackjack a shoe is uh
you know a deck of cards you're going
through it and you know it's just going
great i'm hot and there's a hand where i
get like two eights and i bet you know i
bet a a ridiculous amount of money on
the hand and i'm like all right well i
gotta split that you know i'm talking
too much what does the dealer have when
uh the dealer had a sick showing oh six
shots i never forget this uh and i got
two eights i'm like oh i gotta split
that so i split em and i get another
eight and i was like oh hey scared money
don't make no money uh
all right all right let's go i'm so
excited i split them i give me no no
split that one too another eight four
eights out there i just split them all
at this point little piece of poop came
out my butt at this point
at this point i'm extremely i'm
extremely nervous because i've never
seen anything like this but it's people
around so i'm trying to play it cool i'm
like hey hey all right okay all right
all right what now what we gotta do now
hit that hit the first one a three come
out the dealer looks at me she's like
you gotta double down i was like yeah
yeah
i know i know i gotta do that
i gotta double down on that let's go
ahead and double down she said you want
to see it face up or down i said i don't
want to see it
she put it down the next one comes out
it's a two so now i got a 10 she goes oh
my god got a double tail again
at this point my palms are sweating at
this point
i said i don't want to see it face down
okay the next car comes out i get a 10
so i got 18 on the last one i had
another 10. the dealer had a six showing
okay all right here we go it's go time
the dealer turns over the card
underneath it in slow motion it was i
saw it it was a five i said
i said you you got to be
oh
not like this
not like this
i'm like go slow go slow go slow
you know dylan's are fast to the point
where you can't count like you haven't
you ever try to add it up but you don't
know where you're at
so i know it's a five out there right
she had the five boop real fast it was a
three i was like oh oh oh what's that
what's that she's like are you ready i
said no no count that what is that what
is that
okay
all right all right you got 14. all
right go slow go slow
real fast ace
eight oh my god what's going on what you
got
15.
like slow motion i've never seen
anything like it in my life real fast
what 6 21 she took the money
look she
she didn't even look me in the eye she
said
i just sat there i kept counting it i
was like hold on wait wait hold on
eleven plus three that's the 14 you got
an ace ace
that puts you all right right there i
think you got to
hold on wait a minute wait a second all
right
what i have what are these what what do
i have
lift all that up that's nothing or this
ain't nothing none of this is nothing
huh
here's what pissed me off there's a guy
behind me he goes man that's crazy